i think at this stage before we go to
the minutes of the meeting i'd like to
introduce obviously
mr livingston from the planning
committee who's obviously here
concerning one of the items on the
agenda
minutes of the meeting held on the 15th
of june 2021 i move that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 15th of june be
approved and signed as a correct record
could i have a second please
unless there are any objections i will
take them as agreed
thank you
item agenda 4 planning protocol changes
are now invite estelle director of law
and democracy to present the report
thank you chair um
i think it might be appropriate actually
if i call on
ian
is that all right
um ian's
ian sort of authored the report and uh
it's he
knows all the details and he can explain
it probably better than me is that all
right
thanks estelle thanks thanks chairman um
so the report outlines a change the
council's constitution specifically in
relation to when applications are
reported to planning committee
and outlining what applications are
dealt with under delegated authority
the change that's been put forward is to
resolve
an ambiguity or a gap within the
constitution
as it's as it's currently in place
that
effectively meant that on land that the
council owned
an application could be submitted by a
third party
not the council and that application
wouldn't automatically have to be
reported to planning committee
um it could be dealt with under
delegated authority
the changes come about following a
judicial review decision which is
outlined in the report i believe it said
it should be 1.3 but it's so it says 1.2
but it's the second 1.2
in the report
which was
the outcome of that judicial review
resulted in the planning permission in
question being quashed because in that
instance
there was
um a a perception of bias that was
created as a result of the decision
being issued under delegated authority
due to
various links from the developer to a
company that the council is a party of
and even though strictly speaking the
wording of the constitution had not been
breached the perception of bias was in
existence and therefore the decision was
crushed on that basis the proposed
change is to resolve and remove that
ambiguity and to make sure that it is as
clear and transparent as possible that
any application that's submitted for
planning permission or
consent under the planning legislation
on land that the council owns or indeed
on on land that a company to which the
council is a party to owns
then that application will automatically
be reported to a planning committee
thank you
thank you chair so uh you're simply
agreeing to amend a small bit of wording
in the planning protocol
to require all planning applications and
applications under planning legislation
to be reported to the council's planning
committee
if then it counts if the district
council owns the land to which the
application relates or if a company
which the council is a party to owns the
land to which the application relates
and if i can just be clear chair that
this doesn't doesn't it won't apply if
there's a planning application on land
that has historically been owned by the
council but has since been sold off by
somebody else because we can't have a
situation where planning officers have
to do a
you know
title title register search to find out
who historically is on the line just in
case we may have owned it so it's simply
to do with current
ownership issues or where a company is
involved of which the council may be a
party
i can't imagine there'd be many
situations like that apart from the
specific situation
which was the subject of the jr which
was to do with a company
called east kent opportunities which is
a partnership between thana and kcc
um so i can't think of any other
situation where that might might arise
but mr livingstone is correct in that
the current wording
in the
protocol is very brief
and and it is open to some
misinterpretation and as the judge said
in the jr
he emphasized that there wasn't bias he
didn't think there was bias but it it
the interpretation was open to a
perception of bias
um so so this simply aims to um
to resolve that issue and uh uh
and provide absolute clarity as mr
livingstone has said
so that's the recommendation uh set out
in the paragraph mark recommendations
and that's what we're asking
asking you to agree to and if you agree
then we will in fact we've got a
standards committee on the 25th katie
have we i might be able to
whiz off a quick report so that we if
you agree this we can put that to
standards then hopefully they will
approve it they can go on to council in
december and we can get this sorted and
the constitution changed
um so that's what we're hoping to do
thanks very much
does any member wish to make any comment
uh just a quick question please um you
say land does that include buildings
also
because obviously you could potentially
own a building on someone else's land
lease it for example
yes i think it would it would apply to
buildings on land
yeah and the other question obviously is
that um does that cover if there's a
mile amendment to
um
a listed building or conservation area
and the other one is where we get an
extra bunch because we own the land as
in shotenbane
does that cover that as well
so that is that then got to go always
got to come to committee
um so in the answer to the first
question it's it's any application under
planning legislation so that would
include minor material amendments
changes to a list of building anything
that requires consent under the
under the planning act 1990 um in terms
of the specific question with regards to
schottendein
as estelle outlined that's land that we
don't historically own
sorry we historically owned but we don't
own now
in the specific instance of
the uh
the agreement previously in place which
came to light during the application
being reported to planning committee um
what we would look to do in those sorts
of situations if they arose during an
application is
we would we would likely just defer to
the planning committee and bring it to
planning committee in those sorts of
situations but they are as estelle's
outlined we don't automatically check
the historic ownership of a site because
it's not a material planning
consideration and indeed in that
instance we flagged out with members
because it was considered to be
appropriate given this information come
to light to just raise it as a point but
it's not something that's a key it's not
a planning consideration in the
determination by planning committee
anybody else wish to make any comment
all right do do members wish to make any
recommendations to the standards
committee just the recommendation that's
already in the report yeah
can i have a proposal please
chance
and the seconder
members agree
right brilliant
in that case we'll move on to agenda
item five
and i call upon a cell to present the
report
thanks very much chair so this is a very
straightforward issue
um it's about the mandatory training
which we provide to members of the
planning committee and in fact members
of the licensing board
where it set out in article 8 of the
constitution
so i think we introduced mandatory
training
in uh 2019 i think it says
um and
so far we've been doing it twice a year
it's quite uh a burden on officers and a
bit of a
bit of a pressure on members as well so
the proposal is to move the requirement
to do the mandatory training uh once a
year at least once a year and as the
report sets out that doesn't mean that
there won't be any more training
throughout the year and in fact ian and
his team are very good
about bringing forward training to
planning as and when new developments
happen and there's new legislation or
important things that people need to
know but it just means that the
mandatory training for both planning and
licensing would only be set for once a
year
so that's the proposal simply
thank you very much estelle members can
agree the amendments to the article 8
with any amendments as they consider
necessary or members could reject the
amendment
does any member wish to make any comment
no
do members
wish to propose the recommendation on
the report
could i have a proposal and a second of
them